-I mentioned -- A couple weeks
ago, I was doing --
I have -- I released a
Christmas book, right here.
I always keep it in the top
drawer, barely even closed.
Just a slit -- It's just a --
It's just this -- It's like a --
-I thought that was
an envelope slot.
-Yeah. Well, it's actually
for thick books.
And I wrote this.
I penned this book,
"5 More Sleeps 'til Christmas."
And I was -- I had to sign a
couple of them, you know,
to send out.
So, I want to be
in the Christmas spirit,
so I put on a
Lifetime holiday movie.
And as I'm watching the movie,
my name is just in the movie.
Like, I had no idea.
I was just watching.
It was called
"Christmas Pen Pals."
It was awesome. I loved it.
By the way,
I highly recommend it.
It was really fun. I loved it.
I watched it again.
I made other people watch it.
I go, "Trust me, it's a winner."
-Oh, yeah, we know.
-It's a jam.
-Yeah.
-We all watched it.
-Seen it a few times over.
-Well, let's take a look at the
clip in case you missed it.
Here's a clip.
-So, then I get an offer
on the apartment.
It's insanely over asking price,
and you'll never guess
who the buyer was.
-Yeah.
-Jimmy Fallon.
-Oh, yeah.
-No way! I love him.
-Oh, he's great. He's great.
Really shy,
if you can believe it.
-Yeah.
-Wait.
Why'd you get
the side eye from...
-Yeah, I go -- What does he say?
"Is he a nice guy,
if you believe it?"
-Shy. Oh, she said --
-Oh, shy.
"He's really shy,
if you can believe it."
-Yeah.
-I am pretty shy.
But they -- So, he sold me an
overpriced apartment,
apparently, in this movie.
And I'm like, "What is going on?
-And you paid for it.
-Well, I go,
"Did I just hear myself?
This is so weird."
So I rewound it.
I'm like -- Yeah.
"You wouldn't believe who bought
the overpriced apartment."
Anyway, so, I talked about it
on the show and I said,
"Hey, Lifetime, if you want to,
you can use my name
for any generic
ambient conversation
in your holiday movies.
Go for it.
You have my permission."
And, apparently, they heard me.
And so, this season, they're
throwing them into a couple...
[ Laughter ]
Two have already haired, right?
Do we have a clip of the two
that have aired already?
Take a look at these.
They slipped my name
in the background of these.
-We can have a donation box
or a sign with instructions
where people can give money
to the toy drive.
I'll host, of course.
They don't call me the
Jimmy Fallon of Maple Grove
for nothing.
-You know, I heard Jimmy Fallon
does this every year.
-Jimmy Fallon works with
Santa Claus?
-[ Chuckles ]
Oh, yeah, big-time.
-Yeah.
-This is better than Shark Week.
-"Jimmy Fallon
works with Santa?"
"Oh, yeah."
"They don't call me the
Jimmy Fallon of Maple --"
What was the first one?
-Maple Grove.
We can just show that first one
one more time, real quick.
-We can have a donation box
or a sign with instructions
where people can give money
to the toy drive.
I'll host, of course.
They don't call me the
Jimmy Fallon of Maple Grove
for nothing.
-She gave a little shimmy.
-Yeah, a little shimmy
on that one.
I loved it, man.
I got them all on DVR because
I want to make sure that I --
I watch them in, like, blocks.
I can't wait.
But, anyways, they hinted that
there is another one
coming up on Friday called
"Dear Christmas."
-Nice!
-I don't where it is,
so it's like Easter eggs.
So if you watch the thing --
Yeah, if you wait around,
once you hear my name --
I don't know, again,
if it's good or bad.
-More. Make everyone do it.
-They should all do it.
-Everybody do it.
-You need some sort of
challenge.
-Yeah.
-Oh, yeah.
-Yeah, like, if folks are able
to string together
an actual scene that makes sense
using all the dialogue
where Jimmy Fallon is mentioned
in the
Lifetime holiday specials.
-Well, that is a bigger thing.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. I want to go
international, too.
[ British accent ] I mean, like,
"Oh, you wouldn't believe
who I ripped off this morning."
-Dream big. Go ahead.
-"From American telly,
Jimmy Fallon.
Yeah, he brought this
crappy tree,
and I sold it to him.
He got totally ripped off.
You wouldn't believe,
he's a little shy in person."
[ Normal voice ]
I love that they took it --
I love that they did it.
Thank you, Lifetime.
I will be watching.
I'll be listening.
I'm like Santa, man.
You better watch out.
Yeah, I know what you're doing.
I know if you're naughty
or nice, but that's alright.
I dig it, Lifetime.
Thank you so much.